can I ask you a question guys I don't
you're you're a hip-hop guy yeah
sure I mean you had a hit hit song yeah
right yeah la you're seeing what's going
on with Kanye these days okay the guy's
talking about you know having opinions
sometimes extreme opinions have extreme
consequences you see what's happening
with Kanye Adidas just dropped him this
is after you saw the sign on the 404 on
the highway basically saying we stand
with Kanye you know 405. 405. my bad
four or five okay you know Kanye is
right about the Jews these anti-Semitism
things he said he's gonna go Defcon 3 on
Jews
I mean you're talking about Kanye here
who basically look I boil it down to
music business and life so if you factor
in music as someone who understands
hip-hop and has had done music like his
music in my opinion he was on Goat
status his music has gone downhill over
the last five years or so since
graduation and all that good stuff done
to album and life of Pablo not exactly
lighting up the church as previous
um albums or review from Coachella
removed from Rolling loud CAA dropped
him Def Jam dropped him now Adidas has
dropping on me if uh doesn't no longer
work with The Gap Vogue Balenciaga the
list goes on and on and then you couple
that with the fact that you know
everything that happened with Kim it
kids you know his mom passed away
depression bipolar like all he has left
is at the seams as he bought parlor and
he's doubling down on White lives matter
and doubling down on Maga it just seems
like he's [ __ ] losing it I'm not sure
if this is a cry for help I'm not sure
if this is like he's just like burning
all bridges like it just seems he's
going down the tubes in my opinion and
this is someone that I had the utmost
respect for years ago but he's losing it
and he's doubling down on anti-Semitism
in Hollywood anyway I'm just teeing this
up for a conversation as someone who's
white your your wife is or your ex is
black I'm not I'm not married no your ex
you have a black half black half white
just like him you're in hip-hop point is
you're in La you're you're around this
culture you must have some opinions on
what Kanye's got going on right now
I honestly haven't been paying attention
to it at all no no I mean no I mean it
seems like there's always something
going on with him so it's like what else
is doing you're just tuning it out can
you zoom in into that other article you
went into go into the other article so
so zoom into that I want to see what
it's saying on the bottom of is that CNN
zoom in right there what it says under
the picture to see how they're
describing that picture right there zoom
in a little bit more a photograph shared
on verified the campaign Twitter account
of LA mayor candidate Kevin bass shows a
group of demonstrators with ban banners
showing support for rapper Kanye West
recently anti-semitic remarks on a LA
freeway overpass Saturday CNN has
blurred a portion of the image that
included a reference to a website
with anti-semitic content so what is the
reference of the way they're having
their hands being held are they are they
waving out the cars going by or are they
saying those are neo-nazis Pat these are
neo-nazis giving their waves are you
being serious what do you mean no no no
no but are you being serious that you
believe that yes you so you're being
serious to believe oh what are these
guys doing do you think they're waving
at cars in that picture God you are
those are you're just as much part of
the problem that you're just tell me
what that means I listen do you
understand how easy it is for me to pay
a hundred bucks to each of these people
to go stand there and put their hands up
and I give you 100 bucks do that for 30
seconds let me just get the picture go
home are you saying that's what's
happening all I'm saying to you is you
can't be that naive and not be skeptical
to think that during election time
anything's being used to divide the hell
out of America that's a different story
no it's not a difference you're saying
this is a political prop all I'm saying
to you is this image what this does is
it it creates emotion
okay which is what it just did to you
and it's meant to do that so it won now
you can't sit there and say I don't
really know if these people are actors
or they're real who the [ __ ] would take
that acting who the [ __ ] wouldn't take a
hundred dollars right now hundreds of
dollars to go pretend you're you know
what you can get for a hundred dollars
now wait do you you but you have to
understand this if you fully believe
that they're standing there doing this
defending Kanye a black man neo-nazis
are defending do you realize how dumb
that is to even believe that that has
nothing to do with Kanye it is the fact
that he is supporting anti-Semitism no
it's not which is what these people
stand for if so ants neo-nazis would
support a communist philosophy okay
Judaism and it's anti-zionist I'm not
I'm not here I'm not here that's exactly
what I'm saying I'm not defending Kanye
I'm not defeating the opposition all I'm
saying to you is pictures produce
emotions and these people in politics
are brilliant if they want to defame
anybody there are so many creative ways
to do it this is one of them that
produces emotion out of someone like you
and you have to go out there and say
Connie has lost his mind and he's doing
XYZ that's what the position has to be
Pat what there's two separate things
that are going on here yeah there's
whatever Kanye is doing yeah whatever is
doing sure anti-messemitism Defcon free
talking [ __ ] Adidas will not cancel me
Adidas will not cancel me we'll get into
here in a minute this is my point is
there two nuances yeah Adidas will not
cancel me I can say anything I want Well
turns out Adidas just did cancel you
homie turns out what you're saying does
every precaution does that have to do
with this picture don't change subjects
stay on this picture I said specifically
I'm gonna make two points give it to me
that was point one okay point two people
have eyeballs people have eardrums
they're seeing what Kanye sang yeah
these [ __ ] scumbag neo-nazis I don't
believe they're political pawns I
actually believe they didn't get paid a
hundred dollars to go do a sea Kyle I
actually think they're taking a message
and amplifying it and showing up in La
you're part of the problem I'm part of
the problem yeah you know why you're
part of the problem please tell me why
you want me to really tell you why
you're part of me okay what that what
what is the whole premise behind
innocent before proving guilty right
okay versus guilty until proven innocent
okay okay you know how many let's see
more images you know how many times you
ever seen these pictures that show
media's manipulation showing someone
getting stabbed and then you open up the
picture like oh [ __ ] I didn't see this
how many times an angle of a picture
like this looks like they're flipping
them off and they turn it around they're
like this do you know how many ways
there is to to produce emotion out of
people like you to say what you just
said and everyone's gonna sit there oh
my God I can't believe that's what
happened I freaking hate Kanye you know
this guy's a this is relax guys relax
you don't have all the Intel I don't
have all the Intel this could be right
but it also could be wrong for me to say
100 this is wrong or 100 this is right I
am naive I refuse to be naive and
manipulated by the same damn media that
divided America over the last six years
and now their ratings suck because
people figure their [ __ ] out that's what
I'm not willing to do okay yeah I I
think you like bringing up a really good
point because
this is my take right is that like
somebody could come in here right now
and say
hey Chet your family uh drinks
adrenochrome you do you do all you do
this that and the third you guys are you
called me every name and book they could
say the most [ __ ] vile [ __ ] to me
imaginable right
and and I could go
okay that's your opinion right I don't
need to go rally and create an entire
campaign to like ruin this [ __ ]
person who I don't give a [ __ ] about
these guys are probably because he he
stated an opinion right like
like uh [ __ ] uh Andrew Tate right
okay
you asked me how do you feel about
Andrew Tate right
well
if I say I like Andrew Tate
then I get classified as like a
misogynist
if I say I don't like Andrew Tate then
then I'm completely denying all the
intelligent things that that man has to
say here's the fact okay do I agree with
every single thing that he says does he
have some hot takes yeah he's got some
hot takes okay do I do but but here's
what people don't understand is that
like if you want to make an impact you
have to be polarizing right that's the
reason why he he
achieved so much success because he was
polarizing right
that's why he even his message he was
even a part of you know the the public
spheres because he's polarizing you have
to shake people up a little bit right
but it I don't no matter what he says I
I don't I'm not taking it personally
right I I I can I can I I how hard is it
to allow a person to speak their mind
about anything
and and and not want to then like
just go to completely start an entire
like like black ball it's like the Salem
Witch Trials to anybody can say anything
I'm not gonna [ __ ] crucify them for
stating their opinion I even if I don't
agree with it right
like what what happened to this what
what happened to this this quality of
allowing someone to just say say an
opinion or anything that's on their mind
within having to crucify them if you
disagree with them
do you know what I'm saying I know fully
what you're saying and I and I'm fully
with it all I'm saying is to folks out
there is don't be naive to jump to
conclusion what these guys do listen if
there's anybody right now Adam
tell me tell me who uh and this goes to
everybody when he goes to Kanye West
we're going to go back to Kanye West
here in a minute tell me who has high
credibility right now low credibility
right now who's trusted today so let's
go through I'll ask the question
give me a score for them from zero to
zero to ten hang on I'm going to ask you
the question you give me the answer from
zero to ten
um
pastors zero to ten
pastors let me change the word priests
not pastors
not as high as they could have been or
should have been okay all right let's go
to the next one how about uh
um I don't know uh college football
coaches do they make positive impacts or
negative impacts on kids life for the
most part positive okay cool how about
military generals positive positive how
about uh politicians very negative very
negative okay how about the media
not trustworthy how about billionaires
in reality trustworthy
according to a lot of people
untrustworthy got it so but in reality
they're creating jobs okay I agree how
about social media virtual governments
good bad positive negative all the above
at once okay how about universities
colleges our current educational system
uh has skewed way too far left out of
everything I just said to you which one
of those has the least credibility today
politicians and then
uh I would put one universities I would
put one before politicians you know who
it is you know governments no it's media
media okay I would put media doesn't
have
credibility today okay absolutely so for
me for me to sit there and see every by
the way I just sent you a couple
different things I want you to see this
so here's what I want you to look at
okay
here's what I want you to look at I'm
going to send you these pictures and I'm
going to do an airdrop and uh uh Tyler
if you can pull these up okay that's one
of them perfect that's exactly one of
them I was sending to you just zoom in a
little bit so people can see it
from this angle looks like he's flipping
flipping them off from the other angle
looks like what so guess which one's
going to get more eyeballs why would I
use the picture on the right
use the picture on the left people are
going to look at that article more okay
go to the next one I just sent you okay
go to the next one I just sent you okay
go to the next one I just sent you
the the image I just sent you look at
this one here
can you make it uh are you getting it or
should I just text it to you
Tyler did you get it or no okay yeah I
would like to see how the media back to
the Neo-Nazi thing in La I'd like to if
you're right I will gladly on air say
that I was wrong no no but Define right
when I say if I'm right what is right
what am I saying to be right what was my
point of being right
you're saying that possibly the media
manipulated this story of neo9 I'm right
you're 100 right I'm a hundred percent
right that possibly they could use that
but you're also 100 wrong potentially no
no like maybe they were actually Nazis
100 wrong you're 100 wrong because
you're saying definitely that's
neo-nazis you're 100 wrong what I'm
saying is no this could possibly be
wrong and we have to understand look at
this here the TV you look at that image
right there it looks like a guy stabbing
another guy but you look at the picture
it doesn't look like a guy stabbing the
other guy's stabbing this guy we we
cannot be this naive today so so when
will we find out the truth then dude
some [ __ ] takes 30 years to find out
what do you talk with Russia took three
and a half years Iran what happened when
Iran took us 30 years for CIA come out
with movies to tell us what really
happened with Us's involvement in
Kissinger Carter all it took us 30 years
to figure some of this stuff out yeah
but this is a little more black but it's
not more known because these are
professionals you have to understand
when you're going up against
professionals you're an amateur compared
to mainstream media these guys wake up
in the morning saying how the hell can I
get you to get pissed off and produce
emotions that's their job yeah that's
what they do by the way rappers hip-hop
artists what song produced emotions give
me one hip-hop song that produced such
emotion that we played it when we were
working out in the 90s what was the song
hit him up hit him up produced emotions
yeah Tupac knew what he was doing it
produced emotions we're like hell yeah
okay what other song by Bone Thugs and
Harmony produce emotions we're not
against ram we're not against rampers
but we are against those thugs thugs
Thugs and we're like oh my God this is
sick that pretty good you wanted to work
out through that album more murder than
all these guys right you you have to
know these are professionals so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]